look outside here's what we got uh we're
looking here from the strat camera
looking to the north obviously you see
circa there the plaza a las vegas city
hall with their lights that make it look
like it's raining we got two 100th of an
inch of rain that puts us at 1.6 inches
of rain for all of 20 21. we're going to
be far behind normal although we'll have
a better shot at some rain again during
the day tomorrow
another shot on late monday night and
tuesday but let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's stick with the right now
temperatures 50 is the official number
out at mccarran everybody hanging at 50
or better we've got a bunch of 51s along
the west side of town and to get some
damp roads hector is going to talk about
that 54 is the warm spot down in the
southeast but we do have 55s for
downtown and along the strip and
checking nevada and beyond it is back to
the big chill up north after cloud cover
kept ealy in the 30s yesterday now down
to 21 may dip into the upper teens cedar
city 39 everybody with the lingering
storm clouds beginning to push out to
the east kingman good morning with your
48 54 for death valley and again
laughlin has proven to be the warm spot
at 60. so we are going to turn things
back around it is a real temperature
roller coaster ride that we're taking
here
60 was as far as we got yesterday our
current temperature the low so far that
is 10 degrees above normal we're going
to be upwards of 10 degrees above normal
on the high this afternoon as we go back
to the upper 60s but then it's going to
take another deep dive so here's this
area of low pressure you can see what
was left of the rain beginning to fade
out and roll out to the east but we are
keeping an eye on what's going to be
windy
stormy and much colder getting ready to
dive right into our backyard here during
the day today checking in on your family
and friends uh kind of a double whammy
here it's going to be a big snowstorm
for the northeast while it's going to be
mostly rain in the mid-atlantic states
all right your eight day forecast
down to 58 with wind and storms tomorrow
maybe a tenth of an inch accumulation
then down to the low 50s and lows in the
30s only 50 for the high on saturday
before we turn things back around to 60
monday and another shot at rain on
tuesday